here we have the pdb entry 3wu2
this is a structure of the photosystem 2
complex that plays a pivotal role in
photosynthetic light capture and water
splitting
in this tutorial we will explore this
structure using some of the molestar
viewers animation capabilities
under export animation there are a
number of animation modes to choose from
the one we will explore right now is
camera spin the default parameters for
duration and speed will produce one 360
degree rotation that takes four seconds
to complete
for now let's proceed with these
settings to create our first
animation
before we hit render though we need to
adjust the resolution under the camera
icon
for this tutorial i'll be going with
dimensions of 1280x720
which are good dimensions for uploading
to youtube
now you may have noticed that the
resolution displayed in the animation
panel does not match the resolution set
above
that's because we have auto crop turned
on
once we turn it off
the resolutions match up
now we can render the animation and wait
for it to export
with the rendering complete we can hit
save animation to receive the file into
the downloads folder
and here is the finished animation
returning to the mall star viewer we
will now cover the customization of the
camera spin parameters
let's say we want the structure to
complete two full 360 degree rotations
instead of just one
to do this we will adjust the speed
slider to two
however notice that the duration is
still at the original 4 seconds this
means that the spin cycles are probably
going to be too fast
to solve this problem we can set the
duration slider to 8 seconds preserving
the default ratio of one rotation per
four seconds
in your own projects feel free to
experiment with different ratios to
create animations of varying rotational
speed
for this tutorial i'll move ahead with
the current settings by clicking render
and downloading the file once the export
is complete
now the structure makes two full
rotations but at the same speed as
before
it is also possible in the mall star
viewer to animate specific parts of a
protein structure in this next animation
we will visualize photosystem 2's active
site which is where the water splitting
reaction occurs
to do this we start by unrolling this
drop down menu and selecting item 20 the
calcium manganese oxygen cluster
then upon clicking oex as shown
a rendering of the cluster appears
to make this depiction a little clearer
we can go under components and hide the
cartoon ribbon by clicking the eye icon
if we want we can also remove some of
these interactions by going to these bar
controls selecting non-covalent
interactions and turning off the
hydrogen
bonds once we land on a good orientation
for the active site we can optimize the
animation parameters
there is a lot of detail to take in here
so we should choose a moderate pace for
the rotation
something like 7 seconds for the full
360 degrees
as before we hit render and download the
resulting file
and here is the completed animation
finally i will demonstrate another
animation capability that the mall star
viewer has to offer
spin structure
instead of producing a simple rotation
around the y axis like camera spin this
mode will turn the structure end over
end the default duration is a bit fast
so we will extend the slider to 5
seconds as before we click render and
then download the exported file
and here is the finished animation
you